hey guys it's just data today we're
checking out a very expensive iPhone
case the contents of this box is two
thousand two hundred and eighty three
dollars for an iPhone case and you might
be like Justine fabula official I lost
your mind these are sort of more like an
art piece like you buy an expensive
piece of art you're paying for an
expensive piece of heart so if you like
art by art if you like expensive iPhone
cases I guess by survival gateless well
it so special about these is they are in
limited quantity and they are made of
aerospace titanium so does that mean
that my phone can go to space this also
comes in a titanium color a stealth a
gold and Aurora and the one that I got
is gold so they did send me this to
check out they also sent me one of their
cases before that I was super in love
with so let's just open this up I mean
this case alone feels like a million
bucks I'm so excited
[Music]
this is so industrial like look at this
oh my gosh there's like the pieces to
like put it all together so just take a
look at this grade five titanium there's
little screw so I'm assuming this is
right where you unscrew and then you
have to actually store this into your
phone this is gonna look so good I mean
a better look good cuz like about 17
iPhones for that oh my god look at this
tiny little screwdriver listen here more
extra extra screws this is cool look at
this it's like a little car this is so
sharp person who follows the crowd is
doomed to go no further than the crowd
that's actually a really great quote hmm
so let's put this on her phone oh my
gosh it's so beautiful I hope it's for
the tennis max or I'm gonna have a
problem oh shoot this for the tennis but
it is
that's what tennis yeah that's a problem
because this is for this it's for the
tennis not the tennis max so I guess the
good news with that is that means that
this one is actually cheaper with this
fitness mags fergan I think it's like a
hundred dollars less I wished that it
would fit on my phone I mean this is
also my phone that's slide down I've
done it wrong I've missed something this
is what you need you need these little
bumpers I was like this isn't right
so you put this on first oh yeah there
we go that fits much better it looks so
cool and futuristic like my phone looks
like I don't really have Power Ranger or
something I love how this feels too
because it's like a nice grip I wish
this was for the 10s max but honestly
this looks great like this looks so cool
but since it is the 10s it's a little
bit cheaper let me see how much this one
is it is two thousand two hundred and
eighty three dollars where
the 10s max is 2530 $1 if you want to
buy both of them it would have been four
thousand eight hundred and thirteen
dollars anyway thank you guys for
watching I just wanted to show you this
case because I feel like it is
definitely something that is a work of
art I love the Aurora color that they
had - it's kind of like a purplish tint
this is number nine of a hundred of
these cases so there's only 100 of these
out there how much do you think is too
much for an iPhone case I would love to
hear some on their website right now and
I'm reading it says aerospace-grade
titanium it has two blocks at aerospace
grade titanium the intense four axis
operation requires 12 hours undertake
overseen by only one of our most trusted
artisans ok ride this was company they
also have a cryptocurrency wallet like
how much is that okay let's see you the
gold cryptocurrency wallet oh that's
only $1,500 for the gold one so right
now I have a cryptocurrency wallet he
doesn't see why phone cases in the total
six thousand three and seven let me know
if there's anything else crazy that you
would love for me to check out I mean
this is pretty insane but all things
considered it is really beautiful like
it does look so good on my phone
this case like wow it looks so good I
will see you guys in my next video if
you're not subscribed be sure to do so
already and make sure you hit the bell
because I think that's the only way that
you'll get notifications and when I post
a new video super super excited for 2019
tech I keep saying that but it's like
I'm just like counting down the days
until all the cool stuff starts coming
out you feel like the end of last year
it was just so overwhelming with
everything there were so many phones
what is that sound like what are you eat
is that I don't know well I'm gonna go
investigate see what that sound was and
I'll see you guys later
I'm gonna go put this in a safe
somewhere very very precious cargo
[Music]